alright let's go and check on the latest
madness in the public school system
shall we always a fun topic I point you
to an article in The Daily wire
yesterday headline is drag queen jessica
lahore visits middle school after
backlash school issues partial apology
and the article says in part after
backlash from the community a school
district in Colorado has apologized to
parents for not notifying them in
advance that a drag queen who goes by
the name of Jessica Lahore visited the
school for career day the district said
it would not apologize however for
inviting the drag queen to talk to the
middle schoolers a decision the school
made in the name of inclusiveness and
diversity Adams 12 5 star school
district admitted that a spokesperson
for the school
admitted that the staff of Rocky Top
middle school should have notified
parents in advance about what they knew
would be a controversial event which is
the visitation of Jessica Lahore who
dressed which is not his Christian name
I assume who dressed in drag he spoke to
four different classes of six to eighth
graders read a book on bullying and
answers answered questions about
negativity and hate Lahore said that he
spoke to a bunch of classes they asked
great questions he also said this he
said there were a lot of kids interested
in how I could have the confidence to go
out looking the way that I look which
his um I hate to tell you mr. Lahore I I
don't I think that may have been a bit
of a backhanded compliment when you go
to somebody who say what do you think of
my outfit and they say I mean it looks
like you got a lot of confidence
dressing like that I don't think that's
a compliment this is what I'm trying to
tell you Lahore dresses as a woman
professionally a day job that the drag
queen says involves traveling around the
country working six days a week the
spokes the spokesman for the school
district said that parents should have
known in advance who was going to be
speaking and that didn't happen in this
particular situation parents just needed
to have more info in context about what
was going to be talked about and some
background on this individual and they
weren't given that information the
principal of the school also apologized
but
apologize not for telling care didn't
apologize for the event apologize not
for telling parents that's the only
thing they're apologizing for
well [ __ ] himself said his message to
parents is I'm not telling your kid to
go off and become a drag queen I'm
telling them to have the conversations
because it will come up in life well sir
let me just say this is delicately
looking it's not your job sir to tell my
kids anything do you understand it it's
not your job to tell anyone's kids
anything it's not your right to try to
indoctrinate other people other people's
kids into your way of thinking and
actually you say that this conversation
comes up in life but really for most
people it doesn't for most people this
conversation they never have to talk to
their kids about drag queens because it
never comes up it only comes up when
people like yourself bring it up if you
wouldn't bring it up it would never come
up all right let me just let me just
make a few points here if I could first
we should stipulate that this is not an
unprecedented thing this is part of a
larger trend this effort to push drag
queens on kids has been going on for a
while the overall effort to promote
deviancy to children has been as the
left has been doing that for decades of
course but recently they have really
focused in on this specific project of
getting drag queens and little kids
together
they're very obsessed with that so
they've got the drag queen story hours
and everything they want to get drag
queens and they want to get little kids
they want to get them together it's a
very strange very bizarre thing but the
left is the this is one of their their
new and most favorite methods of
indoctrination and why do they do this
what's the point I mean keep in mind
again just emphasize this drag queen was
at the school for career day career day
as if any parent in their right mind
wants their child to become a drag queen
as a career and I know when I say that
you know III know what I just said is
would be considered controversial or at
least what I should say is a lot of
people would pretend that what I just
said is controversial what I'm saying is
no parent in the right mind almost no
parent wants their kid to become a drag
queen and then now you might start
typing furiously say well you're a
bigoted how dare you say yeah except
that you know that I'm right don't you
so think 99% of us we that's that's the
interesting thing about these kinds of
conversations that 99% of us agree in
our heads we know we all feel the same
way because we're normal of course we
don't want our kids to become drag
queens of course we don't want that you
want your kid to become a doctor an
engineer a lawyer I did you know that's
what you want you want your kid to have
to have kids and be a parent in them in
a spouse and that's what you want for
your kid you don't them to be a drag
queen going around the country calling
him - calling themselves a [ __ ] dressed
in in in makeup and dress that's not
what you want for your son nobody does
but you feel like you have to pretend
otherwise so 99% of us agree but over
half of that 99% think they have to
pretend they don't agree and what I'm
telling you is you don't have to pretend
it's okay to be normal
you're a normal person you're a normal
parent you don't want that for your kid
that's normal that's healthy that's
loving and it's okay to be normal and
healthy and loving so just admit it is
what I'm saying I think with so much of
this stuff with especially when it comes
to the really fringe radical methods and
strategies and and messages of of the
left almost none of us really agree with
that stuff in our minds when the left
Commons comes and says oh you know a man
can be a woman if he feels like one 99%
of us we know that that's nonsense
that's crazy we know that so just admit
it
you're allowed to say it and I'm not
saying you're allowed to say it because
I give you permission I'm saying you're
allowed to say it because the
Constitution gives you permission
because God gives you permission with
your freewill all right but they say so
you know what's the reason that they
give for doing something well they say
it's about fighting bullying but we
don't obviously we don't need a drag
queen to tell us not to bully anyone can
tell you that a drag queen has no
special anti-bullying expertise in fact
this guy who now goes around in dresses
and makeup and wigs and calls himself
Lahore he pretty clearly never learned
how to deal with bullying he's basically
the last example you want okay show the
kids someone who was bullied in school
and then became an astronaut a doctor an
engineer a healthy normal person show
them that person a CEO you know don't
show them someone who was bullied and
now spends his life doing this obviously
this person has suffered trauma and
challenges in life and we all have
challenges like but they never
discovered a healthy outlet for it so
this is the last example we should want
to put in front of our kids also when it
comes to bullying I think there's a
deeper reason why they bring in a drag
queen to share this message because what
they're trying to tell the kid our kids
is if you see a man carrying on this way
if you see a man acting in a clearly
outrageous unhealthy perverse way you
shouldn't treat them any differently or
act as though he's engaged in anything
strange so this is an effort to
normalize perverse behavior they call it
anti bullying that's not what it is
it is normalization because it's not
bullying for a person to see this this
this guy dressed this way prancing
around it's it's there's nothing
bullying about noticing that and
thinking well that's abnormal that's
strange that's not right that's not
bullying obviously bullying is never
okay it's never acceptable
but it's also true that mr. Lahore um
he's acting strange what he's doing is
not normal it's not healthy it shouldn't
be treated as though it is if my kids
saw something like that and they said
well that's weird
you know what I would I wouldn't say oh
no don't worry we don't call that weird
no that's that's normal that's not that
that's that's great that's but I would
be so proud of you son if you did the
same thing no I wouldn't tell my kid no
what I would say to them yes you're
right that is weird
now we don't call him weird okay we
don't say that about people we don't
insult people
but what he's doing how he's behaving
that's weird
you're right now we don't be unkind we
won't be uncharitable we won't be
abusive we won't be mocking but yes
that's weird we should have sympathy for
this person he's very troubled he's
obviously a very troubled person but
you're right that what he's doing is
what that's what I would tell my kids
that's what I have told my kids and I
know I know the left hates to hear that
there's a day that well you're I mean
you're you're raising your own kids how
you want how dare you yep that's how I'm
raising my kids and there's nothing you
can do about it I'm raising my kids to
find that kind of thing weird I'm
telling them it's weird yep
that's what I'm doing because they're my
kids and I can raise them not you so you
know this guy what he's insisting is
that we pretend his whole routine is
totally normal it's not we shouldn't
have to go along with it
and you know if I there's a certain
amount of pointing and staring that you
clearly have earned if you go out and
and and carry on this way if I if I
strap a pineapple to my head and then
walk outside and go to the store or
something and people point and stare and
say that guy's got a pineapple on his
head I can't say well how do your
bullies stop bullying me how dare you
notice this pineapple that I've strapped
to my head and then walked outside of
the house specifically so that you would
notice the pineapple I mean when you
dress in an outrageous ridiculous way
people are gonna notice and that's the
whole
reason that you're dressed that way so
don't pretend like you're being
victimized when you're getting exactly
the reaction that you want by the way
even if this was an actual woman dress
lit like this and calling herself Lahore
my reaction would be very similar and I
would certainly say that that woman
should not be in a school that's my
other problem with this drag queen stuff
I don't know why haven't feminists
spoken up about this these guys are
making a mockery of femininity
they're appropriating femininity and
making it into a joke a spectacle how in
the world can you say that it's
inappropriate for a white woman to wear
like a Native American headdress but
it's perfectly fine for this guy to
dress like a female character from some
weird Tim Burton film and call himself
Lahore and then portray womanhood that
way how is the one appropriating
reductive and exploitative but the other
isn't I mean this fella when he dresses
that way what he's saying is this is how
I see women it calls himself Lahore he
dresses in the ridiculous outfit and
he's saying this is to me this is what a
woman is that's offensive I mean you
should be offended by that I don't want
my daughter to see that because I don't
want my daughter to think that's what a
woman is he's making a mockery of
womanhood and he's using it as a gimmick
I mean think about that
he's dressing up as a woman and calling
himself a [ __ ] what how would the
feminist not all over that how is that
any different from from a you know a guy
dressing up in a ridiculous Native
American costume and calling himself you
know some some slur for Native Americans
I mean what if a guy for Halloween
dressed up a Native American costume and
painted his face red well we would say
well
terribly offensive the native so how is
that how is it a this is exactly the
same thing second point I want to make
this is not the first time that I'm
gonna say this it's not even the 100th
time Mamillius to be said once again
that this is this is what public school
is folks this is how public school
operates this is the point of public
school now I know that not all public
schools are going to invite drag queens
for career day I think we we may have a
few more years before that becomes the
norm but I'll tell you what is the norm
the norm is the schools making parenting
decisions for you the school's deciding
what sort of person they want your kids
to be and then working to turn them in
to that kind of person without your
input without your consent
that's not only how public schools
operate that is why public schools exist
the government has a public school
system so that they can shape the next
generation of people that's the point of
the public school system it's not about
just teaching it's about shaping forming
molding guiding instilling values and
those values are going to be the
mainstream secular values of society so
all you need to do is look at the
mainstream secular values in society and
decide is that what I want infused into
my kids head for seven hours a day five
days a week nine months a year for the
next thirteen years and it's not like I
have no dog in this fight by the way
it's not like I you know it's easy for
me to be anti public school because I
don't have kids I do have kids I have
three kids the oldest are five so our
decision to not do public school has led
to many difficulties and challenges for
us already and we're still very early on
so I get that public school is easier
cheaper and all that I mean it's it's
such an easy decision to make and there
are so many practical advantages to it I
definitely acknowledge that but and I
acknowledge also that there are still
people who
really they have no other choice if
you're a if you're a single parent for
instance well what do you you know and
you can't afford private school then you
what are you gonna do you really have
very few options so I understand that
but for those of us who feasibly
plausibly could have any other option I
think we really need to consider those
options because this is public school
that no matter what you say no matter
what you do no matter how you approach
it they are going to want to parent your
child and turn your child into the sort
of person they think your child should
be education isn't and and and I'm not
saying that well the public school there
they're so biased in the problem isn't
that they're biased in their education
education is by nature biased because
education by nature is not just about
passing on information in a sort of
detached objective robotic way in
education is about making people it's
about forming it's about imparting
values you know passing on belief
systems
you know instilling priorities and
principles that's what education is
that's what education has always been
and always will be and it will never
ever change we have this fantasy of
objectivity like we think it's possible
that we think it's possible for there to
be a truly objective unbiased news
source and what we learn is it's
impossible and the news media for as
long as it's existed has always been
biased because there are human beings
behind it there are human beings passing
on the information and they have views
and ideas and priorities and that's
inevitably going to come out well even
more that's even more the case for for
for education that there's going to be
in a gen
an objective beyond just putting
information in their heads these are
people after all who are doing the
educating and these are people who run
the schools and they all have belief
systems and ideas and everything else
and they're also operate very
importantly here they're operating on
within a system that itself is certainly
not objective a system that itself has a
agenda in mind so that even and there
are plenty of very good public school
teachers plenty of devout Christian
public school teachers conservatives
religious you know public school
teachers but and and many of them work
heroically to stand against the tide but
the fact remains that that it that there
is a tide and they are standing against
it and those kinds of teachers they are
you know if you said your kids in public
school those teachers are very those are
those are like oasis in the desert an
oasis of sanity and reason that your kid
might might come across which is great
but that's not how the system in general
is set up and so we just have to ask
ourselves is this the environment that
we want to put our kids in and it is
very possible I don't deny it it's very
possible that you could send your child
if you're a religious person if you're a
conservative if you care about so-called
Family Values objective reality ejective
objective truth objective morality all
that kind of stuff you could send your
kid into blowback to public school and
it's quite possible although I think
probably unlikely but it is possible
that they could come out on the other
end with their heads still screwed on
straight and with all of those values
still basically intact but if they
accomplish that it will be in spite of
their education and in spite of the
environment the atmosphere they've been
immersed in for the last 12 13 years and
so what we have to ask ourselves is it
is that fair to our kids that we expect
them to be good people in spite of their
education when in truth they should be
good people good decent normal healthy
people in part because of their
education education is supposed to
strengthen you it's not supposed to be a
necessary evil it's not supposed to be
an obstacle for a kid to get around or
over or climb over it's not supposed to
be that's supposed to be a an advantage
it's supposed to be a good thing that
that helps a kid boosts him up not
something that drags him down so he's
constantly trying to climb and resist it
and all that I think that's something we
really need to think about but then
ultimately make our own decisions and if
you happen to send your kid to that
middle school and in in Colorado
I hope certainly hope that you will
demand even if fruitlessly you will
still demand and never stop demanding
that every single person responsible for
bringing that drag queen in is fired
because that's what needs to happen
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed